[Musique]
allez petit intermède divertissement
tours de magie s'est passé la deuxième
carte
alors voilà c'est parti je vais vous
demander n'aura de choisir une carte je
ne veux pas la voir je ne la connais pas
ne veut pas en entendre parler
montrer leurs travaux à me montrer à vos
amis montrer cette carte que je vais
essayer de retrouver tout de suite en
mettez la dans le krach t voilà un peu
mieux voilà c'est parti je vous
demandais s'il vous plaît de mélanger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
semoun de coupe est à mon avis un truc à
vous est toujours étonnant les magiciens
à les écouter à la basse et j'espère que
je vais la trouver
ce n'est pas cette carte je le sais ça
n'est pas celle ci non lieu
je vais peut-être laisser celle ci c'est
peut-être un orage besoin sa vraie pas
celle ci ça n'est pas celle ci c'est là
je vais demander à cyril hanouna de
retourner cette qu'à aller là bas c'est
dingue si c'est celle ci s'est alors si
c'est ça la pour le diable si c'est ça
les îles si j'étais désolé si c'est
celle là moi je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous vraiment on me confirmer ya aucun
trucage vous ne connaissez pas la
personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]